okay I think we should be getting
started
I'm statically verse the co-director of
the program in Hellenic studies here at
Yale University I want to welcome you
all for this annual stuber's Neos
foundation lecture which honors the
foundation by the same name thanks to
which we are able to organize a variety
of activities in the context of this
program just to remind those of you who
are new to it that we have two different
sets of activities we offer a number of
courses both in Greek language Greek
literature and history and also we
organized a set of outreach activities
public lectures conferences of which
this year we have a very rich set of
activities and I'm well I welcome you to
be on our mailing list and be informed
about all those activities we have a
very interesting program coming up we
were very grateful to the Stavros
Niarchos foundation for this support and
it's always a good opportunity to remind
those of you who may not know of him of
the of Stavros Niarchos
one of the most important economic
personalities in Greece big name in ship
owning the tremendous set of activities
and of course he left a very big part of
his money for the creation of this
foundation we just really undertaken a
very wide range of activities in the
last few years one of the most well
known and high-profile activities of the
foundation in Athens has been the
construction of the new national library
of Greece along with the new opera hall
on the coast of Athens which is
transforming the entire area it should
be ready in about a year and a half but
on top of it they've been supporting a
variety of activities in the field of
research in universities in both Greece
and the rest of the world but also after
the big economic crisis hit Greece
they've undertaken a number of
important activities on the
philanthropic side in Greece both as a
set of measures of relief there but also
new initiatives which is extremely
ambitious and extremely welcome to help
with the very important problem of youth
unemployment there we organize every
year a major lecture which honors an
important contribution in the field of
either research that have to do with
Greece or other artistic activities as
well we've had over the years the
pleasure to welcome here some very
important contributors to the study and
understanding of various facets of
Greece especially modern Greece which is
what we focus and so it's with great
pleasure today that I would like to
introduce Artemis Cooper who is a well
known writer has written extensively
about various aspects of I would say
European history and its ramifications I
had not realized how many of my friends
for example were familiar with your book
Carrio in war 1939-1945 which i haven't
read but after the enthusiastic reaction
I got from my friends I feel that I
should and today she's going to talk to
us about the subject of your latest book
which is a biography of Patrick Leigh
Fermor
now but really thermal is an interesting
person in two respects at least first
for who he was who he was through his
writings that who he was really and I'm
not going to say much about that because
that's precisely the topic of the book
but he was one of those quintessential
British characters of the mid 20th
century this combination of adventurers
and travelers extremely learned but also
very very much interested in
understanding shall we say the grass
roots so traveling around areas of
Europe that were not very well known
participating in various activities
during the Second World War on the
resistance front especially in Crete
kidnapping a German general about which
I'm sure that we're going to hear some
and also and of course writing a set of
books about his travels that provide a
very interesting angle from which to
understand modern Greece and its
evolution but what is also very
interesting and what I hope to learn
more about tonight along with you is the
fact that he even though he I thought he
was probably an obscure person only read
by Greeks because he wrote so
extensively about Greece and because he
chose to leave all his life in Greece in
money where he built a beautiful house
in cardinally I was surprised to learn
of the extent which is developed a cult
following the extent to which people
still read his books retrace his travels
visit the places he's been and are
fascinating by his personality which is
also reflected in the fact that the book
his biography has attracted so much
attention and so that is my my big
question tonight and the issue on which
I hope to learn more how this particular
person or the particular set of
interests and and life choices he
represents have been able to be so
enduring and to survive the test of time
so much success so I'm very pleased to
welcome tonight Artemus Cooper tonight
to discuss with us your purer book your
biography of Patrick Leigh Fermor and to
learn more about this fascinating
personality thank you very much for
coming
oh good evening ladies and gentlemen
it's a great honor to be here in New
Haven to talk to you about Patrick nee
firma
in Greece and I would love to thank the
Niarchos foundation and of course the
Hellenic studies program for inviting me
to give this lecture and special thanks
to to George sue Ramiz and statistically
of us who have made my short stay in New
Haven so interesting and enjoyable thank
you
the other thing I'd like to say before
we begin is that Patrick Lee Firma was a
close friend of my family's for decades
so although it would sound much more
professional to call him lee firma i
find myself always reverting to paddy
which is the name by which i've known
him since he was a child so sorry since
I was a child biographers are supposed
to be objective and dispassionate and in
my book I really did try to be so but I
can't change the fact that I found him
one of the kindest and funniest and most
interesting people I ever met if anyone
was blessed by the gods it was Patrick
Lee farmer he was born with Byronic good
looks intelligence and talent and one
reviewer remarked that he had dodged and
survived so many attempts on his life
that he made Rasputin look like a
quitter
here was admired as a writer and as a
war hero women found him irresistible
almost all his books won prizes and if
this isn't enough to make you boil with
resentment there's more all his life
paddy had the gift of making people feel
happier and funnier and better read than
they'd ever suspected as one of his old
friends put it
if only paddy came in pill form so you
could take one whenever you felt
depressed and he lived with such
intensity that perhaps he didn't write
as much as he should have done but on
the strength of what he did produce John
Morris and Bruce Chatwin have both
hailed him as the greatest travel writer
of his generation and although he lived
in Greece for over 40 years he remained
unmistakably British his Greek though
fast and fluent was marked by a
pronounced English accent and while all
the food and wine at his table was Greek
he still clung to his tea and marmalade
and whiskey and the times and yet he
felt happier more relaxed more fulfilled
and more alive in Greece than he ever
did in his own country in England during
one lovely English summer he told a
friend how much he was missing Greece in
spite of all this green Pacific beauty
he wrote this is not my world it's like
living in the heart of a lettuce I'd
pined for hot stones and thorns and
olive trees and prickly pears his years
of travelling began quite suddenly in
December 1933 when he was 18 years old
after a turbulent school career he
decided to leave England and cross the
whole of Europe on foot from the hook of
Holland to the city more commonly known
as Istanbul although he always called it
by its Greek name Constantinople to set
out on this epic walk he said was my
first independent decision and perhaps
my first sensible one he would live on
his allowance of 4 pounds a month which
in today's money I worked out was
probably about two hundred and fifty
dollars
his father who was the director of the
Geological Survey of India had said that
this allowance would last until paddy
was 21 and since paddy resolutely
refused to show any interest in
preparing for a career or a profession
heaven knows what the boy was going to
live on after that paddy had no idea
either all he wanted to do was write and
decades later he would describe the
journey in two of his best loved books a
time of gifts and between the woods and
the water he reached Constantinople on
New Year's Day 1935 but the journey did
not end there in Bulgaria he'd met some
Byzantine scholars and talking to them
had awoken a burning desire to see Mount
Athos where the traditions of the great
Byzantine Empire of the east still lived
on paddy spent a month on the holy
mountain and with the help of the monks
the smattering of ancient Greek he'd
learnt at school began to turn itself
into demotic and after that he went to
stay with a friend who bred horses for
the Greek army and joined his hosts at
stream or nickel to witness the last
phase of the short-lived Venizelos
revolution rebellion of March 1935 paddy
asked if he might keep the horse a
little longer and so began his first
travels in Greece he rode eastwards and
had not gone far when he came across a
group of conical huts he had seen such
huts before and knew that they belonged
to the sarah-cat Sahni those aristocrats
of the Greek nomadic world he was very
impressed and intrigued by their
self-sufficiency and that this
extraordinary contrast between what
seemed to be on the one hand a life of
perfect freedom and the rigid customs
that governed everything that they did
paddy spent most of the next month on
horseback exploring the wilds of Thrace
and the road open mountains and he was
amazed by the generosity of the people
he met and without even knowing it they
gave him a gift that was as precious as
it was unexpected in the 1930s
the constraints of the British class
system were much more stifling than they
are today
and the contrast between England and
Greece in this respect was a revelation
he became aware of a direct and
immediate link between human beings
friendly and equal on either side
something which melts the barriers of
hierarchy and background and money and
except for a few exceptions of politics
and nationality as well
allowance must be made for the fact that
he was very young and a foreigner and
the Greek tradition of hospitality is
very strong but he wrote the passage
that I've just quoted thirty years later
and by that time he knew Greece
extremely well and had built a house
there but that sense of easy and
unforced equality was one of the things
that he most valued about being in
Greece he travelled south by bus I
should say because by now he'd returned
the horse to Athens and there in the
spring of 1935 he met the group the
first great love of his life a romanian
princess called balagia Cantor Kuzon she
was sixteen years older than him and
here she is during their first summer
together working on a portrait of her
young lover he and balagia spent the
next four years together mostly in
London and Romania and Greece and as
soon as war broke out in September 1939
he hurried back to England to join up
this photo was taken in Venice his first
trip to Venice as he was on his way back
from Romania to England by now he could
speak Romanian as well as French German
and Greek and this ease with languages
brought him to the attention of the
intelligence corps he trained as an
intelligence officer and was sent to
Greece in November 1940 as part of the
allied military mission to the Greek
army and attached to the Greek army he
spent several weeks in the mountains of
Epirus and explored the borderlands
between Greece and Albania
by March 1941 the Germans were massing
on the Bulgarian border and on the 6th
of April they started to pour through
the monastere gap and when paddy
returned to Athens towards the end of
the month the Allies were in full
retreat by slow degrees on a number of
increasingly unreliable boats carrying
more and more people paddy
eventually landed at Castel eiki-sama in
Crete in early May 1941 and he was
appointed liaison officer to the staff
of Brigadier Chapel in the her athlean
sector and from here he witnessed the
German German airborne invasion and the
surreal sight of wave after wave of
paratroopers landing in the olive groves
around her athlean and despite furious
resistance by the 28th of May the
Germans were in command of the western
part of the island now of course the
Germans saw all this purely as a an act
a very successful act of war and they
were shocked when the Cretan civilians
instead of meekly cooperating with their
new masters attacked the invader with
the same ferocity that they deployed on
the Turks 300 years before and yet for
all their bravery and despite huge
German losses Crete fell to the enemy in
late May the bulk of the Allied army
including paddy was evacuated by the
Royal Navy but many lost and wounded men
never made it to the evacuation areas it
was the Cretans who fed and hid them for
months at a time and formed networks to
get them down to the south coast from
where eventually they would get away in
small boats paddy spent the next year in
Cairo and Haifa being trained in
clandestine warfare and he was inducted
into the highly secret special
operations executive or SOE which was
the British equivalent of the American
OSS and he was smuggled into the White
Mountains in Central and Western Crete
in June 1942 as one a handful of SOE
officers whose task it was to support
the Cretan resistance networks now of
course the information being gathered by
cretins at this time was crucial since
the Germans were using Crete as a huge
transit camp refueling station and
supply depot for their war in North
Africa most of the intelligence was
gathered great personal risk by local
people employed by the occupiers and it
was then passed on to runners who took
it into the mountains where secret
wireless stations relayed it to Allied
GHQ in Cairo paddy is always associated
with the celebrated capture of general
creeper but his first 15 months in
Western Crete were every bit as exciting
and dangerous and I don't think that the
cry per operation could have taken place
without the experience and contacts that
he'd made during that first spell of
duty on the island I'm just going to
point out a few things of course you've
know the geography but the Germans are
strongest in this western part of the
island with their capital here at Hanyu
and they control the West that these
central sectors - with their
headquarters at arcanas and retinyl and
this eastern part of the island is
controlled by the Italians with their
base there at Neapolis and here is a
rare photograph of paddy in disguise
with his hair and moustache dyed black
but although he could look the part his
Greek was very obviously that of a
foreigner and on the few occasions when
he had to take a bus or walk through a
proud crowded place he was
uncharacteristically silent while his
Cretan companions had to pretend that he
was a simple-minded cousin paddy
relished the excitement of clandestine
life in the mountains and like the
cretins he was addicted to poetry and
song he learnt as many Cretan songs as
he could and his favorite was set to an
old Turkish tune and it was called Fela
dem and in fact he sang it so often that
Philadelphus codenames wireless activity
could be detected by a German
reconnaissance planes so the heavy sets
and batteries and chargers were often
moved
at night usually on human backs over a
terrain where every rock is sharp and
jagged and every plant is bristling with
thorns in January 1943 when paddy and a
group of cretins were shifting the
equipment yet again
they were almost ambushed by several
hundred Germans who had fanned out
across the hillside to look for them and
paddy and two of his companions had to
spend the whole of one freezing day in
the thick branches of a cypress tree
while the Germans thrashed about
literally below their feet and in May
1943 there occurred an accident that was
to haunt paddy for the rest of his life
he and his guide Yani Tseng gareki's in
this photo there at the front there with
about a dozen [ __ ] and artists were
resting on a ridge above the village of
Hanoi yeah then their lookout appeared
with the news that about 300 German
soldiers had been spotted making their
way up the valley now this was no
immediate cause for alarm the Germans
were always prowling around but luckily
they never they never left the main
paths they didn't they couldn't find
reliable guides the guides would lead
them out into the open and then leave
them so they usually stuck to the main
paths where they could get back home
again
so everybody reached for their rifles
which had been oiled that morning and as
he held the gun downwards paddy drew the
bolt backwards and forwards easing the
springs and as he did so he accidentally
pulled the trigger and found that the
gun was loaded the bullet ricocheted off
a rock and it hit Yani Tseng haraki's
through the thigh he was sitting on the
ground doing up his surrey key and it
sort of passed through his body like
that on the ricochet and within an hour
Yani Tseng Arrakis was dead of internal
injuries paddy you can imagine was
shocked and appalled by what he'd done
and he wanted to go immediately to the
zanga raucous village of 14 oh and tell
what had happened to ya nieces family
and beg their forgiveness but all the
cretins
president absolutely refused to allow it
they knew that yeah nieces death have
been a tragic accident but in these
difficult times they said evil tongues
would say that paddy had killed Yanni's
as a traitor or because he knew too much
and they made Paddy's swear that he
would not go back to 40 knew until after
the occupation was over and will pick up
this story again a bit further on and a
few weeks after this event in July 1943
Mussolini fell from power and was
replaced by marshal Badoglio and the
Italian troops occupying the eastern
part of the island were delighted they
thought they were soon going to be home
again but their commanders foreseeing an
armistice feared that they might be
interned if they didn't surrender their
weapons to the Germans which was
obviously the last thing they wanted to
do and it was at this point that general
Angelo carta commanding the Siena
division in Neapolis secretly got in
touch with SOE
to explore the possibility of making his
escape from the island paddy was keen to
help and with several Ketan Cretan
guides he has courted the general over
the Lacetti mountains to the south coast
where a naval launch was waiting just
offshore and Paddy very polite has
always followed the general on board and
although he planned to return to the
island within the hour the wind suddenly
got up and the sea became so rough that
the captain refused to lower the tender
again so paddy had no choice but to
accompany the general all the way to
Egypt he made the most of his unexpected
leave in the fleshpots of wartime Cairo
this sketch by the way is by Keith
Douglass who was one of the best of the
soldier poets at the Second World War
but wherever paddy was and whatever he
was doing he had a lot to think about
and having taken an italian general off
the island he now conceived a plan for
kidnapping a german general and not just
any german general but the brutal
general friedrich wilhelm Euler
divisional commander of the Huracan
sector who had been responsible for a
series of savage reprisals in the v-a
nose area
Crete shortly before paddy had left the
island and this plan was given the
go-ahead by SOE Cairo and Paddy put
together his core team this consisted of
two seasoned resistance fighters Manolis
Petrakis and George T Rockies but Paddy
also needed someone who could pass for a
German and who was for who was a good
driver and his choice fell on a young
officer called William Stanley moss and
in February 1944 paddy was parachuted
into a little Bowl in the mountains
southeast
yes sort of around there southwest of
Neapolis in these mountains here and
it's a tiny little saucer of a thing and
it's February and the rest of his team
would you to follow right behind him out
of the same plane but the dropping zone
was so small that they couldn't be
dropped in the usual sort of stick
formation the pilot had to make a
complete turn 360 degree turn of the
dropping area and then dropped the next
man
so Paddy's dropped shines his torch to
say that he's landed ok and in that
moment a blizzard gets up and the pilot
is forced to turn back and they make
various sorties again trying to get the
rest of the team in and it was seven
weeks before the rest of the team could
join him and in that time the hated
mullah was promoted and moved to Hanyu
and it would be absolutely impossible to
abduct him from there where the Germans
were strongest
and Paddy now feared that the whole
mission would be aborted but SOE in
Cairo decided to go ahead anyway on the
principle that one general was as good
as another and the new target would be
Mueller's replacement in the herati
insector and his name was general
heinrich crapper and no one knew very
much about him since he'd only just
arrived from the Russian front
general Crapo was seized on the night of
the 26th of April 1944 on the road
between his HQ unknow arcanas which is
there and his villa at Knossos which is
just south of her
him he was bundled into the back of his
official car where patty raucous and T
Rockies held a knife to his throat and
Paddy sat in front wearing the generals
hat while Billy Moss took the wheel and
thus they drove right through her
athlean past 22 German checkpoints they
abandoned the car just there on the
north coast opposite this little island
and then they meet up with her that's
where the car was man and then they meet
up with the rest of the team in the
general here at da Noya and they take
him over Mount Ida on scenery T
mountains and through the amariah Valley
somewhere around here and then they
finally get him off the coast somewhere
around Radha keno and before abandoning
the car paddy and T Rockies could not
resist breaking off its two official
metal penance which had served them so
well as they drove hooting imperiously
through the her Ackley and checkpoints
and they gave these as souvenirs to
Billy Moss who was an exceptionally good
driver with nerves of steel and they can
now be seen in the Historical Museum a
threatenin and in years to come
paddy was often mortified and upset by
tabloid retellings of the abduction of
general cry / which seldom mentioned
their [ __ ] guides and lookouts nor the
villagers and shepherds who kept them
hidden and fed terrible risk to
themselves so although there isn't time
to mention all the cretins who were
involved I will tell you the names of
those who appear here
oopsie wrong button that is Gregorius
Nara Keys Stratos saveloy yeah keys
Manolis Pat Iraqis unknown is Papa
Leonidas George T Rockies Niko's kumys
and echoes Billy and Paddy in front but
were still left with the question why
did they do it
kidnapping general creeper in May 1944
could not advance the liberation of
Crete by a single second
Paddy's answer to that question was that
in the early stages of
occupation SOE had encouraged the
cretins to hold themselves ready for an
allied advance to liberate Europe
through Greece and the Balkans by 1944
however it was clear that the advance
was going to be through Italy and the
Cretans now felt sidelined if not
forgotten and to steal a German general
from under the very noses of the enemy
would give a great boost to Cretan
morale and make the Germans look
exceedingly foolish
this slide shows George T Rocky's and
Dan Denis and Manolis whose job it was
to guard the general and liaised with
the local guides they relied on avoiding
the Germans who had poured into the area
to look for the general the abductors
marched for 18 nights across the island
paddy calculated that at any time
probably over 200 cretins would have
known roughly where to look for the
Strategos and his captors no one gave
them away the general was amazed to see
the trust and cooperation between the
British and the cretins who refused all
payment for the food shelter and
protection that they gave the kidnappers
and then three months later the Germans
occupying Crete launched a campaign of
such brutality that it has never been
forgotten one has only to walk through
the Omari Valley today and to see the
memorials to the hundreds who fell
during those terrible days of August
1944 to realize the scale of this
atrocity in which over a thousand people
were killed and 28 villages destroyed of
those 28 villages the Germans declared
that seven had been burnt because
general creeper and his abductors had
passed through that area one of them was
an numerous where this monument
commemorates the victims but there were
other reasons for this destruction which
spread far beyond the Amaury knowing
that the war was almost over and almost
lost the Germans were planning to pull
back to the west of the island and they
did not want any trouble from the Cretan
and artists as they did so and there had
also been a
number of desertions in German ranks and
by turning every one of their men into a
looter and a killer
the Germans guaranteed that no future
deserter could hope to be fed and
sheltered by the local population as the
Allied soldiers had been in 1941 this
was the view of SOE s final report on
its operations in Crete
but because the cry for operation had
been so dramatic because it was the
subject of a best-selling book by
William Stanley Moss which was
subsequently made into a film with Dirk
Bogarde they're taking the part of major
Lee firma the abduction I think took
more than its fair share of the blame
for their reprisal zuv august 1944 the
operation is still remembered with great
pride in crete and of course a certain
ambivalence was it really worth it asked
one old man to get one general off the
island paddy was haunted by the
reprisals and often found himself having
to defend the operation not so much on
his own account as for his brother as
phase [ __ ] brothers-in-arms and all
the people who had helped them so
valiantly at the end of the war paddy
got a job as deputy director of the
British Institute in Athens where among
his friends were the diplomat and poet
George safaris and George cuts in Belize
one of the great figures in modern Greek
letters and an olympic-class recorder we
saw each other almost every day wrote
paddy fondly sometimes in yanagi's more
often frequently in the older posters or
lower down under the wide eaves of the
Platanos Taverna in fact paddy seems to
have spent more time in the cafes and
tavernas of athens than he did in the
British Institute and when he was in his
office it sounded as if there was a
Cretan party going on and yet Paddy's
Cretan friends had come to Athens in
desperation looking for work
paddy gave them floor space in his room
at the hotel grand Bert onion and his
office was there Rhoda
which didn't make him very popular with
his colleagues so it was suggested that
he embark on a lecture tour to talk
about British cultural subjects such as
Lord Byron or the pre-raphaelites
Brotherhood perdy lectured in sparsely
attended halls until he reached Corfu
where the British council's work was in
the hands of an enterprising woman
called Maria a sporty she told Patti
that people wanted to hear him talking
about general cropper not English art
and literature and she hired an enormous
cinema for the evening of his talk and
to Patty's astonishment it was packed
with new phousi astok audience and from
then on he talked about the creeper
operation all over Greece this photo was
taken at some point during the time and
I hope you noticed he was very fond of
sketching the little details around his
map of Crete so we've got a little
galleon here little Zephyr blowing the
wind and a sort of Loch Ness monster
down here but although the lecture hall
was considered a great propaganda
success for the British the council had
no wish to have paddy back in Athens and
he was fired in December 1946 more or
less the first and last job he ever had
paddy was miserable but in one way it
was a blessing he did not have to watch
Greece tearing itself apart in the agony
of the Civil War and just before the end
of the war paddy had met Joan Raynor who
later became his wife she was a very
remarkable woman a seasoned traveler and
a very good photographer and in the late
1940s she accompanied him on a journey
round the islands of the Caribbean which
was the subject of his first book but
they both loved Greece and in the early
1950s they traveled together to the
remotest and most inaccessible parts of
the country paddy was to write two books
on these journeys but before he written
either of them he translated the wartime
memoirs of his friend George sequin
duckies
this is Paddy's wartime sketch of sequin
duckies
who is a poor shepherd from a mountain
village in crete called oz Agana boys
like him were taught to read and most of
them could just about write their names
but George with the help of the village
priest had taught himself how to read
and write with fluency he was 21 when
war broke out and he worked tirelessly
for SOE all the way through the
occupation and although he was awarded a
medal by the British in recognition of
his courage when the war was over he was
thrown into prison as a deserter because
his military papers were not in order
cygwin darkus wrote his war memoirs to
keep himself sane during the months he
spent in prison and paddy was so
impressed by the account that he
translated the book himself and
persuaded his publisher John Murray to
publish it
Paddy's own two books on Greece Manny
and Rumeli have never been out of print
and I would like to give you a little
taste of his style and sort of the
aspects of Greece that he celebrated is
it romanticized yes of course it is I
love it this is a particularly vivid set
piece and it's constructed almost like a
piece of music not all his writing is
like this it would be awful if it was
but I think it gives you an idea of the
effects that he could achieve it's from
his book Manny which was published in
1958 paddy and Joan are on board a
little sort of ferryboat ke key which is
full of people and chickens and goats
there's somewhere between one island and
another in the lake Oney engulfed soon
the delighted cry of then fenya went up
a school of dolphins was gambling half a
mile out to sea they seemed to have
spotted us at the same moment for in a
second half a dozen were tearing their
way towards us or surfacing in the same
parabola and plunging together as if
they were in some invisible harness and
soon they were careering alongside and
round the boughs and under the bowsprit
glittering muscle
on top feeding at the sides through
gunmetal dune like markings to pure
white streamlined and gleaming from the
elegant beaks to the clean cut flukes of
their tails they were beautiful
abstractions of speed and energy and
power and ecstasy leaping out of the
water and plunging and spiraling and
vanishing like swift shadows each soon
to materialize again and sail into the
air in another great loop so fast that
they seem to draw the sea after them and
shake it off in midair to plunge forward
again tearing to grape frothing bow
waves with their beaks diving down again
falling back and Criss crossing under
the keel and deviating and returning and
sometimes they flung themselves out of
the sea with this insane abandon in
Reverse of a suicide from a skyscraper
up up until they hung poised in midair
shaking in a muscular convulsion from
beak to tail as though resolved to
abandon their element forever but
gravity as though hauling on an oblique
fishing line dragged them forward and
down again into their rifled and
bubbling Greek green tunnels the
headlong speed through the water filled
the air with a noise of rending and
searing and each leap into the air
called forth a chorus of gasps and each
plunge a sigh these creatures bring a
blessing with them no day in which
they've played a part is like other days
I first saw them at dusk many years ago
on the way to Mount Athos and a whole
troupe appeared alongside the steamer
racing her in keeping us company for
three-quarters of an hour and slowly it
grew darker and as the night fell the
phosphorescent water turned them into
fishes of Pale Fire white hot flames
world from them and when they left from
the water they shook off a million fiery
diamonds and when they plunged it was a
fall of comets spinning down fathom
after fathom league upon League of dark
sky it seemed in whirling incandescent
vortices always to rise again until at
last streaming down all together as
though the heavens were falling and each
trailing a
of blazing and feathery wake they became
a faraway constellation on the sea floor
and then he suddenly turned and vanished
dying away along the abbess like ghosts
and again four years ago I was sailing
in a yacht with some friends through the
other Cyclades through the outer
Cyclades in the late afternoon of a long
and dreamlike day there was another
visitation a few bars of unlikely
midsummer cloud lay across the West all
at once the sun's rim appeared blood-red
under the lowest bar hemming the clouds
with gold wire and sending a Japanese
flag of widening sunbeams alternating
with expanding spokes of deeper sky into
the air for miles and spreading rose
petals and sulfur green across the silk
lake and then some distance off a
dolphin sailed into the air and then
another and yet another until a small
company were flying and diving and
chasing each other and hovering in
midair in static semi circles gambling
and curvetting on almost playing
leapfrog trying to stand on tiptoe
pirouetting and jumping over the Setting
Sun and all we could hear was an
occasional splash and so smooth was the
water that one could see the spreading
rings where they swooped below the
surface the sea became a meadow and
these antics like the last game of
children on a lawn before going to bed
meaning spellbound over the bulwarks and
in the rigging we watched them in
silence and all at once on a sudden
decision they vanished just as they
vanished from the side of the Aphrodite
in this chapter off the stern and
shadowless rocks car lane near the
Delfina
the captain said when they had gone
there good
Patty always found writing a very very
slow and laborious process but as he
worked on money in the mid fifties he
became more and more anguished by the
situation in Cyprus the Cypriots of
course were calling for enosis with
Greece while the British determined to
hold on to this base in the eastern
Mediterranean refused even to negotiate
during the war paddy had been willing to
die for both Greece and England and now
he had to watch the two countries he
loved best treating each other as
enemies he was in no doubt that English
that the British policy in Cyprus was
morally indefensible and strategically
disastrous and yet and yet he was still
enough of an Englishman to deplore the
way that the Greek newspapers were
comparing the British administration of
Cyprus to the Nazi occupation and in May
1955 paddy visited Cyprus where Lawrence
Donnell had persuaded him to give a
lecture for the British Council and at
this time a ouka the National
Organization of Cypriot fighters under
the leadership of Colonel Grievous were
bombing and attacking British targets
and service personnel paddy joined
Durrell in pathos to witness the trial
of a group of a-okeh rebels who had been
captured while waiting for a key a key
loaded with guns and ammunition and
outside a furious crowd were smashing
windows and shouting for the release of
the accused and the Cyprus situation led
to a dreadful quarrel between paddy and
George get symbolism like most Greeks
but symbolist believed that they owe
yoga rebels should be seen in exactly
the same way as the resistance fighters
in Crete as heroes defending their
homeland against an aggressive enemy and
in the long run paddy was forced to
concede the point he wrote a long
article about Cyprus two long articles
in fact for the spectator in December
1955 there was only one solution he said
which was to relinquish sovereignty
oversight
and seed it to Greece before any more
lives were lost and describing the trial
that he'd witnessed in Paphos paddy
wrote it was depressing to see that
those accused of running explosives into
Cyprus for use against the British were
exactly the same sort of hardy Greeks
that had not only helped us to run guns
and agents against the Germans but had
befriended and sheltered the straggling
remnant of our defeated army at
appalling risk to themselves one of the
most interesting chapters in Paddy's
second book about Greece Rumeli and it
was very much discussed this in Greece
at the time concerns what paddy called
the Helen Oh Rome a dilemma which he
felt defined the experience of being
Greek the Helene is urban intellectual
progressive someone who sees Greece as
part of Europe the romeo's on the other
hand is a countryman conservative and
traditional who sees Greece as part of
the Orthodox world Helene is the glory
of ancient Greece right paddy Romaic the
splendors and Sorrows of Byzantium and
in spirit paddy who certainly felt at
least half Greek by now was a romeo's
and he was acutely aware that Romeo
sinner the Greek village way of life
that he loved and wrote about was in
decline
paddy imagines the Helene asking him why
the poor should be kept in ignorance and
poverty and disease just to oblige a few
romantic travelers and of course paddy
could see the need for education and
health care and economic opportunity as
well as anyone but in the early 1950s he
had also witnessed how the Greek
authorities were conspiring to suppress
many local customs those which the
Orthodox Church found heretic or or
indecent and the government regarded as
backward and primitive among them were
the firewalking rights of the Anniston
re who venerate saints Constantine and
Helena and walk over burning coals on
their feast day and the phallic
celebrations of clean Monday in tyrnavos
which I will spare you
a glance at YouTube shows that paddy
needn't have worried
both of these traditions and of course
many more are alive and well even of
course now they're performed for the
benefit of the tourists as much as for
the locals paddy and Joan had always
dreamed of settling in Greece and in the
early summer of 1962 they found the
ideal spot a headland surrounded by
olive groves and cypresses overlooking
the sea just south of the village of
Carl Amelie in-the-money and here they
built a house made of local stone
designed by the architect nikos hajima
Callas this is the entrance who had made
a study of Greek vernacular architecture
but why people asked it he and Joan not
settle in Crete and certainly Paddy's
Cretan friends felt rather hurt by the
fact that he and Joan were putting down
roots on the mainland well one reason
was that in Crete he could never really
have lived as a private person this
rather bizarre monument by the way now
stands at the road junction where the
abduction took place wherever he might
have settled on the island his fame
would have obliged him to become
something of a public figure someone who
is expected to take sides write letters
to the papers defend his friends and
take a stand on everything from private
disputes to local politics but of course
all paddy wanted to do was write and in
the Mannie he could live undisturbed and
the other reason he couldn't live in
Crete brings us back to the sad tale of
Yanni's Sangha Rocky's the guide whom
paddy had accidentally killed in 1943 as
he had always intended paddy did go back
to yon ESA's village of 40 new after the
war was over and met Yanni's his brother
Caracas is it true you killed my brother
yes yes it was a terrible accident but
kanakas had turned on his heel he didn't
want to hear another word and from then
on paddy was the target of a vendetta
this meant that he had to be
be careful when he came back to Crete he
often saw Kanaka saw his son waiting on
a hillside with a rifle binoculars but
of course as long as he was accompanied
by somebody who was not in feud with the
Django Rockies he was safe the vendetta
was only lifted in 1972 thanks to the
efforts of Jorge segunda Keyes and the
reconciliation was sealed in the
traditional way with paddy standing as
godfather to the little great niece of
Yanni's Sangha Rocky's whom he named
Johanna after her great uncle and also
after his own wife Joan one morning in
April 1967 Greece woke up to find that a
group of middle ranking army officers
had seized power in the night paddy and
Joan never supported the Colonel's and
many of their friends found themselves
arrested and imprisoned but unlike the
Cyprus question which involved Britain
directly and evoke two passionate
response in paddy he never spoke or
wrote against the hunter in public when
asked why he replied that whoever
governed Greece was a matter for the
Greeks alone when his study was finally
finished this is it looking very clean
and neat paddy settled down to write
though life always got in the way
spring and autumn brought an endless
procession of guests and there were
visits to Crete and Athens and he and
Joan would return to England for a few
weeks every summer in winter this as I
say is what the study looked like when
it was new and this here it is again in
2009 looking more as I remember it he
ordered books by the Dozen wrote letters
in several languages to many of his
friends and he must have subscribed to
at least a dozen literary magazines in
French and English and Greek and it was
in this room that he kept his Cretan
military medals his citations from the
Athens Academy and his Grand Cross of
the order of the Phoenix which is given
to foreigners who have been particular
friends of Greece many people have
compared paddy to Lord Byron and one
can't deny that they both enjoyed
dressing up
yet paddy was always very uncomfortable
when people hailed him as some sort of
avatar of the poet Byron he felt had
given everything for Greece his fortune
his health and eventually his life and
the Greeks had taken him to their hearts
and Paddy felt that every subsequent
Englishman himself included benefited
from the association and basked in his
glory but Paddy too had been an
inspiration
George dunder lackeys who moved to the
US after the war and became head here of
the Crete veterans association
remembered meeting paddy as a very young
man you were a revelation to me he wrote
while everyone in our company pretended
to be a brave pal Akari you were
radiating a genuine fearlessness and I
certainly tried to imitate your calmness
and courage Paddy's wife Joan died
suddenly in 2003 leaving him desolate
but he lived on in the house they had
built together until his own death in
June 2011 and as he and Joan had wished
the house was left to the Beneke Museum
in Athens the idea was that it should
become a writer's retreat or a place for
seminars and conferences but it will
need substantial repairs and
modernization before that happens and as
Dominic Greene in his recent article for
the Weekly Standard which I do recommend
if you're interested in this he makes it
very clear that little so far seems to
have been done writers and editors on LI
firma have been much quicker off the
mark since his death there has been a
biography and I'm sure it won't be the
last
and the final posthumous volume of his
trans-european trilogy has been
published entitled the broken road and
we've seen no less than three books
appearing that focus on Crete and the
kidnapping of general cry / paddy is now
buried in an English country churchyard
beside his wife Joan but as you see
Greece is still with him I'm sure you
will recognise the words that come from
Constantine kavafis poem on the
epitaph of king Antiochus of the coma
Guinea I will not attempt it in Greek
but in English that line and the two
that follow it read thus he was that
best of things
Hellenic mankind has no quality more
precious everything beyond that belongs
to the gods thank you very much I don't
know if anyone's questions but you're
thinking of they were done by a
wonderful artist called John Craxton who
eventually settled in onion in Crete and
he and Patti I mean all of Patti's books
were until sort of right up more or less
to the end were done by John Craxton yes
systems gosh I don't know I don't think
it I don't didn't know that it had a
name it was just sort of the friends and
people he was with I wasn't aware oh I
see when he was with a Greek military
mission or when he was with SOE well
with the creaking resistance but that
was that that was sort of a matter of
people and the Capitan's and you know
the different groups but I'd as far as
I'm aware please somebody call in and
correct my ignorance but I I was I was
not aware that there was a particular
name I mean if it was yeah I don't know
if I can help political affiliation
number of where they weren't the
communists put it that way if I can put
it in a negative
they were probably not sure they were
just working with us oh yes I didn't
think they were yeah no they weren't
sorry there was somebody it was a we're
just spiders in other words there was
the head of the of the resistant
movement of the wars they can do that by
family you know that's right yes a cup
of time yeah sometimes you don't always
know everything what's there something
that really surprised you that you found
out that like saying that what you find
about looking back it's like oh yeah
yeah well I I it was it was
extraordinary I mean I sort of he was a
very very private person so I realized I
hardly knew anything about him at all so
almost everything was a revelation but I
don't know I suppose it was sort of the
extent what surprised me I suppose most
was the extent to which his his writings
particularly the books on that early
journey across Europe were very much
novelized as it were I mean when you're
remembering over 30 years back things
are going to get novelized anyway but
there were certain moments when he very
deliberately changes the story and when
I found out sort of by accident and he
said you won't tell will you and it's in
the book yes
the moment that you describe the
approach might be the end of the data
when when he became the Godfather was
very striking to me did he write about
that no he never did he told me about it
but he never he never wrote about it as
far as I know but again you see where
heaven knows what's going to turn up
because the whole of his archive is now
in the National Library of Scotland in
Edinburgh
in the John Murray archive and I mean I
think probably most most people doing a
biography within a certain get a limited
time for him you don't see every single
piece of paper you're taking core
samples really you know throughout the
continent of papers that there are you
take core samples where you're
interested so these these papers I think
that they are beginning to catalogue
them but it's an enormous work and so a
heaven knows something something might
come up but I think he would have shown
it to me I think he would have authority
surprised put it that way if something
did turn up on that subject I have two
questions one is you talked about his
feelings his conflicted feelings with
the Cyprus problem what about his
feelings if he related them to you or if
you have found anything in his archives
or correspondence about how he felt as
the Germans were retreating and the
British seemed to be rather slow and
following them and then also with that
the Germans were treating where from
Greece Greece we see Ziggy comes off the
island he's very ill by the time he
leaves where he gets the general off
he's suffering from this extra mind of
paralysis and so he's three months in
hospital and actually I think he's all
he's at that point really desperate to
do is the war has sort of gone to the
Far East and he wants to go there but
he's not given a clean bill of health so
I think that's upsetting him far more in
a way than what's going on in Greece
that was in December of 1944 when
Churchill said to Scobie treat Greece as
a conquered country or I don't know he
whoa and there were planes strafing at
them so they came singeth ins didn't he
ever never you never did I think it
would be a you know he appalled by it
obviously but he wasn't
I think well hold on no he was he was
probably because he was working with the
December when was it December 44 no he
wasn't that he was it he was in Cairo
then he was very briefly in Crete and
then he goes back to Cairo so he misses
all that to me about it but I think you
would have thought it was appalling
let's say he started he says and he
explained how the Germans got called out
and they had killed so many people
burned their feelings and so forth
Dumanis is okay we don't have something
you know Saturday but the broken road is
written although it's the last part of
the journey it's written before the time
of gifts on and between the woods and
water it comes first that was written in
the mid-60s and a time of gifts come out
and comes out in 1977 and the between
the woods and the water in 1986 so it's
yeah it's very young what is it that the
broad put English writing either yeah I
think oh they loved him at the time he
was always very very well reviewed I
think they loved that the the mixture I
mean the extraordinary sort of range of
it that you could have a sort of set
pieces like that dolphin piece and then
very very funny stories extraordinary
historical died he was kind of in the
tradition of people like Norman Douglas
and Robert Byron and and I think that
was a very
a style that people really appreciate it
they loved all that learning I mean
people say to me now oh gosh this is
really dense this is really heavy this
is sort of full of you know historical
illusions and you know I feel it's all
going over my head but you know sort of
30 40 years ago people didn't think like
that and they they enjoyed it and so I
think but but he carries on having this
sort of cult status lots of people have
never heard of him and other people
think he's God and you you know this is
everybody else's sort of somewhere in
the middle but why do people have a cult
following I don't really know but
certainly I was astonished at the
interest you know when he died suddenly
everybody wanted to hear about him and
lovely for me you know catch the wave as
it were but yes he does so he does there
was an enormous curiosity and an
interest kind of goodwill to wanting to
know more he was certainly part of the
larger group of people who roads perhaps
he was among the better known one
secured by no means celebrity nxp you
know even though he was life at the time
he's right he is a writing that comes
out at a very specific time yes it is
complete used to generate this kind of
interest and this endurance is very
positive and so I was wondering perhaps
isn't that perhaps the effects of his
personality got a lot of press what
mattered people who he was
as opposed to that kind of right mental
strength been perpetuated or create to
be seem atrophy but what exactly there
has to be something that explains the
fact that is able to generate such a
tremendous interest over dying unlike
many other people well were you thinking
of anybody in particular no but I'm sure
that people will look at this but and
who are who are also very well known and
equally celebrated you know and Wilfred
fessin job just off the top of my head
there are lots of other sort of great
adventurers who were writing astonishing
books there Norman Lewis I think so well
we're obsessed by travelers I suppose I
mean I think it's a genre that's that's
very popular and the fact that he was
sort of world war hero I mean let's face
it that that whole kidnapping of the
general it's sort of the boy's own you
know war story really and I've seen it
in sort of cartoon form and then and
that's the movie and all the rest of it
and it was sort of one of the great sort
of derring-do bits so I think there's
that and there's this sort of rather a
wonderful kind of glamour about it maybe
that's what we're trying to get to it's
perhaps not just the books not just the
kidnaps but something about him as a
personality that people found very
engaging and interesting and maybe boils
down to the fact that he lived a life
that perhaps we all doll rather like to
have lived yes
I didn't edit them no that was Charlotte
mostly sorry in Terry
is there any plan to collect his there
is yes yes where where he has three
literary executives of whom I'm one and
we are actually sort of right now got
two or three people who were thinking
about editing them it's not gonna be me
oh that's right yes yes absolutely
Fitzroy MacLean right yeah we have winds
of war the lady who wrote the theology
yeah oh yes and if you're Manning so you
see all these I mean you know there's
lots of writers they're all celebrated
in one way or another
it's very commissions yeah exactly you
know I think all that all that stuff
comes into it and of course the the
Balkan trilogy and the levant trilogy
were also made into what I think was
actually a very very good TV series with
Kenneth Branagh and what's-her-name Emma
Thompson that's it yeah but I think well
you know she's just had a big biography
done of her
Olivia Manning a recent one driven by
somebody called Deirdre David I think we
we do love all this period yes was from
her a personal religious faith I I think
he would love to have been if you read
his book called a time to keep silence
which is about the monasteries but the
most important essay is the first one
which is about sam von tree in normandy
and he has i think it's a wonderful he
understands so well what the monks are
about and it starts off he goes there
he's only trying to find somewhere cheap
where he can write and he can't write in
paris because you know he goes out and
gets drunk every night and then no work
gets done the following day etcetera so
he goes this monastery where all he has
to do is write and at first he thinks oh
my god you know what am i doing here
it's like being in a tomb you know and
all these men they're not men they're
ghosts and then gradually it's sort of
the peace and the quiet and the
significance of this place begin to sort
of work their magic
and it's the most beautiful passage and
i think there he does describe a lot he
understands very well what the religious
life means what these monks have given
up the sacrifice that they've made and
also the fact that they are still as you
have as many temptations as the rest of
us do and and at the same time sometimes
i sort of wonder that you know he he's
like a like a child looking through the
bakery shop window kind of wanting
something that he just can't get to he's
just
from it and then I think and certainly
during the war on his on his forms he
put down Roman Catholic he was never a
Roman Catholic he was uh he was CV but
he loved the idea of somehow being a
part of this great liturgy of this great
history this all this beauty and
everything like that
but after the war all that sort of
dropped away and Joan was definitely she
was very intellectual very rigorous and
very a theistic and so I think she
probably knocked all that stuffing out
of him yes well he did no yes he had his
arm twisted his wife and his agent and
his publishers were all saying look
patty really got to appoint somebody and
start working with them because
otherwise you can wake up you know a
month from now and somebody will have
done it you know unauthorised so it was
quite important you know to get that
done so originally it was going to be
done by my husband Anthony beaver we've
written a thing of the the battle and
the resistance in creeks and a heat man
Anthony having finished that book wrote
to Patty and said can I write your
biography and there was a terrible
silence so quite obviously Patty wasn't
ready and then some years down the line
Antony sat next to Joan his wife at a
party and she said oh when are you gonna
start pads biography then so I didn't
even know I'd got the job and so he said
well I can't do it but what about
Artemis doing it so that's how it sort
of came up and I eventually did it I
think actually Patti was happier for a
woman to do it and he could see actually
sort of forgot that I was doing it and
sometimes he'd start talking about a
story and that's it oh yeah that's the
time when you didn't he'd say how'd you
know that night I'm writing your
biography oh yes so you are and it was
never very welcome news and they need to
forget about it and we'd carry on
yes thank you compare his experience I
think Greece it's definitely that's the
place where he feels best where he feels
most at home the other places he's
visiting and with Greece I don't know
there's to me anyway those two books on
Greece remember there's you know there's
three books on the great walk that he
did there was one on his first book
which was called the travelers tree
which is about a journey in the Antilles
he's not
you don't feel there that although he's
fascinated by all kinds of different
things and full of stories and said it
never really kind of engages him the
same way that Greece and the Greeks do
you have a feeling he's just traveling
through but in Greece it's personal yeah
they didn't exist and people say how can
you live in Greece and not be
politically you know engage in some form
or other you know it's in the air but
paddy really didn't really like politics
he liked politics when it became history
but otherwise he was conservative
royalist and really not on gaji except
in the sort of major way is sort of war
you know when he was like he was very
vehemently anti-nazi but I think that
was probably and at the time of Cyprus
that was another time but otherwise I
think he wasn't really interested yes
Artemis is a proper Greek name it is so
how did you come about I tell you
exactly my grandmother was called Diana
and so I was called after my grandmother
and given the Greek and I've been
profoundly grateful it's been a
wonderful awful when I was at school you
know artichoke heart attack
the funny thing is is that his mother
was part of the sort of Anglo Indian you
know they had slate mines her family did
and his father was a grammar school
scholarship nobody worked harder
nobody was such a professional as his
father and his father was brought up in
Camberwell and was literally a
scholarship boy all the way through
Wilson's Grammar School Royal School of
Mines he becomes a geologist he goes to
India and the whole of his working life
is in India and paddies mother I mean it
was a disastrous marriage really was you
know as paddy said what were they doing
in each other's company they should
never have been allowed near each other
but his mother was this sort of
wonderful career romantic rather flighty
person and the the Matt that marriage
starts to go sour very very quickly and
Paddy's born during the war and his
mother never she does actually go back
to India at that point but when she
comes back to put him through schooling
and everything she comes back with both
children because he has a sister Vanessa
and so he's absolutely brought up in
England now the funny thing is is that
his sister often goes and eventually was
sort of keeping house for her father in
India but paddy never did and I think
his mother was very very possessive and
he was her boy in and in a funny way
vanessa was you know her father's
daughter but he was he was very much I
think um and it was sad really because
he never really got to know his father
yeah the smoking stopped oh the post of
the Marlboro Man yes exactly
no he well he could he didn't he got
cancer of the throat in 75 and it came
back and that's what killed him mind you
at 96
but it was a pretty good innings